el cáncer de mama provocó en 2020 la
muerte de 685 mil mujeres en el caso de
américa latina- este mal tiene más
posibilidades de terminar con la vida de
las pacientes que en otros lugares como
por ejemplo en eeuu algo debido a
factores sociales y genéticos de las
mujeres de la región en américa latina'
podemos tener un número importante de
mujeres que digamos no tienen el
suficiente nivel de información y la
cultura para examinar regularmente sus
mamas o cuando sienten una masa iu como
el cáncer en de mama en sus estadios
iniciales no es doloroso entonces
posponer la cita para el examen clínico
de la mama pero también se ha encontrado
que las mujeres latinas hay una mayor
probabilidad de desarrollar las
variantes más agresivas como son la
triple negativo una problemática que se
suma a la falta de disponibilidad de
tratamientos oncológicos y de
medicamentos en la mayoría de los países
de la región motivo por el que la
enfermedad puede ser difícil de tratar a
pesar de una pronta detección sólo en
2020 se detectaron
462.000 casos de cáncer de mama y
100.000 muertes derivadas de la
enfermedad en américa latina' un índice
inferior que en otras partes del mundo
pero todavía preocupante por esta razón
cada vez son más las plataformas que
intentan concienciar sobre la dolencia y
ofrecer apoyo a las pacientes tras
situaciones como la pérdida de los
pechos en las mujeres como lo estaba
haciendo ahorita
curiosamente en mi caso lejos de
acomplejar me está circunstancia de no
tener senos ni blindó para mostrarme de
manera abierta mostrar mis cicatrices y
decir ella aquí no falta nada tampoco la
complejidad de esta enfermedad hace que
muchos pacientes necesiten asistencia
psicológica no obstante las
organizaciones de ayuda e insisten en
que contraer cáncer de mama no es
sinónimo de muerte